[Music]
in
airbnb horror story news oh no what
happened now somebody took a dump in the
living room
you read the story i did okay submitted
by your favorite
taco assad
[Music]
i don't know i just eat it it's like
some weird ass meat is that the cheek
the cheek one is good too is that bouche
or cabeza cabeza has the face one that's
the whole [ __ ] face cabeza's
bombastic
face is bomb as [ __ ] but i always go to
average 26 get the [ __ ] buccaneers
that's my [ __ ] or food yeah i've seen it
i don't know what buche is i actually
don't know what the meat is it's just
delicious
yeah i don't know either a couple had to
arm themselves with knives
after their airbnb host airbnb host went
crazy oh
[ __ ] what did they do [ __ ] bath salts
in the [ __ ] living room
why does everything happen remember our
airbnb host in hawaii that went a little
crazy on us
yeah oh yeah what thanks thank god for
this guy yeah yeah yeah
that fool called us locusts yeah did you
know that he called us locust yeah
in the review oh damn well in the
morning jess was
woken up by this [ __ ] angry ass
airbnb owner and then i was listening to
the whole thing he was yelling
at the top of his lungs why are you
doing why you come home why you party
why you do this
and she's like sir you have to calm down
yeah
don't talk to me like that that's very
disrespectful sir that's what she's
saying the whole time
and he's like no no no i told you don't
party don't do this don't do that
and she's like all right if you can't
[ __ ] talk to me correctly i'm not
gonna listen to you she's hung up on him
and he called back again and then i was
like oh what the [ __ ]
you were so so [ __ ] stupid about that
guy you have cameras in your house
you dumb [ __ ] like tell him to go check
the cameras tell him to go check the
cameras right and he goes okay i'll
check the camera right now
one minute later i'm sorry i overreacted
yeah you [ __ ] [ __ ]
what made him think that so the
neighbors yeah
called because you know we were speaking
when we parked the car we spoke on the
way into the house
damn they're just pissed because he's
renting out that house
they don't want him to rent it out yeah
and he should be a good neighbor
and [ __ ] talk with his neighbors
before he does this
right it's not our fault like we have to
[ __ ] tippy toe like
[Music]
like we're not even partying or anything
we went to sleep at 10 pm dude i know
yeah you were saying he was saying like
oh yeah that neighbor is always
complaining all the time
after the fact yeah it was horrible
because jess got the
uh airbnb right so then she was dealing
with all this stuff
and then that [ __ ] was like like
basically
he thought that it was okay after the
fact but she's like
um i gotta write a [ __ ] review and
warn other people
that this guy's running this and he's
not on good like terms with his neighbor
so watch out
take that out on you without even
checking right and then so she wrote
that and that [ __ ] called us
dirty locusts
how dare he you [ __ ] green tooth
chinese [ __ ]
[ __ ] green ass teeth i remember that
[ __ ] he had corroded two front teeth
yeah this [ __ ] was gross but his house
was dope though oh it was a dope house
he's like an architect too or some [ __ ]
right right
it wasn't yeah i liked your house but i
hated your [ __ ] personality and your
teeth yup
all right so this story here is this
couple that
these two anesthesiologists are doing
the residencies in boston they came to
la
and they were staying here for a one
week vacation
and so they're saying that the first
night
at around 5 30 a.m they woke up to
sounds of banging at the door
they got out of bed and they were just
like what the hell and they heard a man
shout
i know you're in there kevin so then she
opened the door
why you confronted the the this man why
would you open the door
and told him to go away so she shut the
door and then
called the the super host because
you know how like they give badges to
like airbnb hosts let me guess and then
the phone was ringing on the other side
of the door
yes oh that's exactly what happened the
cell phone started ringing on the other
side of the door
so then that's when he picked up the
call he admitted
that um that was him that he had done
that he was like yeah that was me
sorry about the confusion life's too
short for me to give you an explanation
have a nice time in l.a
wait life is too short to give you an
explanation
it's a long story joe crazy it's a long
story i want to know
so then the couple they try to brush it
off no you don't brush it
if you woke me up at 5 00 a.m i'm
sitting down for that story to judge if
that was okay or not
if you told me yo man [ __ ] went down
lost three kids
wife gone and this [ __ ] kevin i
thought he was
back at my house again i'm like oh i get
you dude i'll [ __ ]
it's cool man you want to come inside
you know like you want to [ __ ] watch
some cartoons maybe think about some
happy [ __ ]
cartoons man yeah but if he if he says
something stupid like i had a nightmare
the [ __ ] i don't give a [ __ ]
yeah so then they tried pushing it off
right
they had a nice day at the beach but
then the following night
that's when a man crashed through their
bedroom window at about
2 a.m i'm sorry hold on they were
sleeping he jumped
through the [ __ ] window through the
glass [ __ ] batman with the [ __ ]
rope
yeah and then like it just sent glass
flying everything he owned the air
doesn't he have the keys
he could just come inside i bet it's a
code too yeah
isn't it his [ __ ] house why is he
destroying his house or that fool
[ __ ] with the ninja grappling
[ __ ] and then he just swings in with his
leg like
well right when he comes in because it's
not like the movies he just has glass
shards in his face all over his [ __ ]
arms and he landed his face
guess who what a [ __ ] nightmare dude
where's kevin
yeah and it's his house too so if he
comes in and does some violent [ __ ] and
the cops show up it's like
this is your home sir what the [ __ ] okay
these intruders so then that's when the
couple
they were just like what the [ __ ] like
what's happening so then
the dude he ended up hopping on the
intruder and pinned him down to the
ground
and then that's when the girl she ended
up calling 9-1-1 but then she quickly
realized that this was
the super host oh my god jj and then so
but jj was able to free himself and he
ran out the door
couple waited for the police to arrive
and they barricaded themselves in the
kitchen arming themselves with the
biggest knives they could find because
they were just scared like they don't
know what the [ __ ] is happening
so finally quick uh finally cops got
there and they quickly apprehended jj
and so what happened he was on drugs or
something
so i don't know exactly what the hell
this dude was on but it turns out that
he didn't even own that property
what he was illegally subletting that
house because he was renting it from
the lady that lives in the front house
because this elderly woman she came
she came out of the main house and she
was like who the hell are you guys
and then she's like i own this property
and jj's renting for me
he's not supposed to be listing this
[ __ ] on airbnb damn he's double renting
so then um that's in the couple called
airbnb that night and the company
the company agreed to refund them 708
dollars that they had paid to rent the
house
but they're saying that they didn't get
the credit until
the media made this story public and
that's when
the company paid them that's [ __ ]
nuts dude like
let me rent out this house make some
money off of people but also scare them
i know
like if this was some type of experience
like a haunted house experience or some
[ __ ]
he would be making way more money not
only you know do you get to stay
in la but you get the [ __ ] psycho
treatment so in the couple they ended up
getting a room
at a nearby hilton which cost them two
thousand three hundred dollars
including parking and other expenses and
so they asked airbnb
for five thousand dollars to cover that
plus compensation for the traumatic
experience that they had
but then airbnb's final offer was two
thousand seven hundred
and they also offered to pay for five
therapy sessions but the
full the couple declined it so why are
you trying to get money out of it dude
yeah like you got the money back you got
a little extra and they're gonna give
you therapy
you [ __ ] crooks yeah sue the guy yeah
why are you going off the airbnb you
[ __ ] [ __ ]
no that sucks i agree with you guys i'm
like if you really had emotional
distress and take the therapist
take the therapy take the money here's a
few extra hundred bucks you're good to
go the [ __ ] your problem nobody died
or even got hurt this is the couple how
much you want [ __ ] they white
the government they're dying white
yo masters i'm really racist i apologize
what did you say i said i bet you they
white oh
that's how america works right yeah
because if you guessed that race
and then you got it right then you won
the lotto hey [ __ ] you two man what's
wrong with y'all man
what they were victims dude they went
through a very traumatic time that is
crazy they're trying to milk the money
out of it unless some [ __ ]
wearing a cape
and he burst through my window i don't
want anybody to do that even if it's the
homeowner well they [ __ ] up
if you guys were youtubers you could
have vlogged that whole situation that's
true in the middle of the night
yeah oh god oh god hold on hold on so
can you get the camera get the camera
[Laughter]
it's almost like what do you call it
like when people have
uh two personalities or whatever and
they don't like multiples
but yeah they don't know what the other
one's doing or something i feel like
he's like sleepwalking but he wakes up
in the middle of the night and he's like
gotta break into his own house like i
gotta get home
that dude his whole life definitely
wanted to bust through a window and that
was his chance
i've always wanted to do that dude where
you going two feet first like this
and then you gotta make sure you go
right through and then you have to let
go of the rope right in time to land on
your feet
if you don't land on your feet though do
you just roll into a whole bunch of
glasses i wonder if he does this without
people in the home like if it doesn't
get rendered out he's still bursting
through windows like
he has a routine that he does he's like
my bab's working out bro
yeah that is pretty scary do you guys
think twice about airbnb or anything
like that because like we've stayed in
so many and it's always been awesome
except for some
than the last one i think about it every
time i'm constantly looking i think
there's cameras everywhere yeah oh same
here i scope it all out like if i'm
gonna be
in that room or whatever a restroom i'm
like scoping it everything out dude the
worst of my worries is like i hope the
towels don't smell mildewy the only
thing i do is when i open the the
blanket i go hope there's no pubes in
here
yeah if i do get an airbnb i better be
saving a substantial amount of money
because hotels they clean for you it's
not it's done you know what i mean all
the amenities are a lot of free
breakfast places
you know your car's safe it's like you
know what i mean like so i definitely do
enjoy that so i have to save a good
amount of money if it's like i'm saving
20 bucks it's not worth it yeah that's
true when you were talking about pubes
it just reminded me of this uh
when we were in istanbul we stayed in
this hotel and
and i was just so tired that night when
we got there i just
got this for your casey tea baggie or
something hey what the [ __ ] hey stop
no but in the morning when the sunlight
came into the room and i could see those
sheets
clearly there was so much hair on the
pillow
i wanted to throw the [ __ ] out i don't
like my neck hair it was so disgusting
i'm like how could you not change the
sheet what kind was it like body hair or
was it like long hair
curly no it was like body hair like i
can't i don't know if there are pubes or
like beard or i don't know what the [ __ ]
it was but it was like right next to my
face because it was on the pillow
the hotel
this is number one [ __ ] this is
another emotion
you hurt my feelings
[Music]
you